[Musique]
bonjour un nouveau numéro d' envies de
lecture avec nous aujourd'hui stéphanie
férial responsable de la littérature
librairie le pavé du canal laurent garin
aussi le patron de la librairie du canal
et puis un invité et vincent puech
maître de conférences à lui fait est ce
qu est surtout laboratoire dit pas qui
est ce que ces deux laboratoires imac
exactement dynamique patrimoniale et
culturelle d'accord donc au nom de toute
l'histoire de l'antiquité jusqu'à la
révolution
donc on est plein pot dans la dans
l'histoire et dans la culture bon qu'est
ce que vous avez apporté alors cette
fois ci alors on va commencer et vous
dit comment fait tout à fait voir
l'article 353 du code pénal alors qu'est
ce que l'article 353 du code pénal
jean-charles celle intime conviction qui
est laissée aux juges pour donner ses
jugements
voilà où ça va tourner tout autour de
cet article a alors là c'est ce n'est
pas un poids là on sait dès le départ
qui vaille enfin il ya un meurtre on
connaît le meurtrier mais c'est pas du
tout un polar c'est un vrai ouvrages
politiques et sociales
c'est une bonne intrigue une histoire un
début un milieu et une fin oui enfin la
fin on commence par la fin en fait donc
voilà on sait déjà qui qui a fait quoi
et c'est plutôt une confession en fait
un dialogue qui va avoir lieu entre un
juge d'instruction donc et le présumé
meurtrier de cet acte là et c'est ça va
être la façon dont on va décortiquer et
le contexte social politique de l'époque
et comment cet homme a été amené à faire
cet acte là est l'une des questions en
fait central de ceux de ce livre c'est
est ce qu'on peut légitimer la violence
physique vis à vis de la violence de
notre société moderne et principalement
de capitalisme vaste débat
vaste débat vous l'avez lu aussi c'est
effectivement un grand livre
c'est un grand livre c'est un auteur
d'abord notre chaîne beaucoup baissé
entre est une truite
travaux de maison d'édition c'est ma
mission qui trompe rarement
voilà qui est dit peu mais les quelques
livres qui sont édités sont
effectivement de qualité les textes sont
de qualité et la salle est vraiment
parce que là cette longue confession
donc de ceux de cet ouvrier qui a tout
perdu et qui s'est fait avoir par un
escroc est un on peut le dire
il a 20 ans guy viala arrivera à faire
en sorte que ce nous lecteurs on est
finalement aussi cet homme
d'accord il s'est fini très très bon bon
ben écoutez on va se précipiter dessus
vous l'avez pas lu vous pas du tout
n'aurait pas eu le temps long
vous avez le temps de lire des romans un
petit peu assez plu à ses pubs on parle
beaucoup de travail à lire mes collègues
bon on va je vais t'emmener a précisé
que la sache ça sort un peu du champ de
minuit habituellement c'est vraiment de
la littérature
ça c'est vraiment différent de ce qu'on
peut lire de chez minuit habituellement
donc voilà c'est obéissance et un vrai
dialogue mais aux éditions de minuit
soit 100 quand même assez éclectique
ouais mais la sq à la source des bonnes
surprises pour wave par rapport en avoir
discuté aussi avec eux avec les
représentants de minuit voilà c'est
quelque chose de différent mais vraiment
c'est un très très bon et donc on répète
le titre l'article 353 du code pénal
tanguy viel aux éditions de minuit
voilà parfait la suite avec la suite
c'est avec antoine choplin antoine
choplin ya quelques jours dans la ville
de tome alain crozat revoilà là on est
en tchécoslovaquie thomas couderc est un
est un cheminement on est dans une
petite ville à côté de prague
il est passionné de photographie il est
passionné par la nature il est garde
barrière et on est donc à la au début
des années 80 et il va croiser un homme
qui n'est pas encore l'homme politique
qui sera acquis et vaclav havel bavure
qui en fait il va se créer une belle et
forte et simple amitié mais c'est une
fiction sais pas c'est un mélange
d'accord parce que c'est quand même tiré
d'une histoire vraie d'un maghreb avait
là existent et là on est vraiment au
tout début d'une histoire de rappeler
révèle donc en fait il est auteur d'un
match de 2 t à commencer par ces textes
là qu'ils allument des feux si je puis
dire qu'il va effectivement s'opposer au
régime et le livre commence et se
termine par ce a sonné quelques maisons
d'édition 89 d'accord avant la partition
de la tuque et là la seule à qui très
bien on sait c'est un auteur qui a une
certaine notoriété déjà le prix france
télévisions il ya quelques années pour
la nuit tombée oui oui c'est un futur un
grand auteur une petite des maisons
d'édition qui est sur lyon et
choplin ce moteur qui la fosse aux ours
et choplin c'est un auteur qui est
effectivement un peu un peu à part je
trouve dans la littérature française
d'aujourd'hui mais qui est toujours
juste toujours marquant toujours d'une
humanité profonde
ses romans sont pleins de grâce je
trouve
il s'empare en général de d'une personne
sauf à son héros est assez simple un peu
monsieur je dirais pas monsieur tout le
monde mais voilà qu'est qui est simple
mais toujours aux prises avec la
tendance et cosmétiques s'est pas
monsieur tout le monde parce que c'est
pas forcément monsieur tout le monde
c'est quand même ses personnages son
sein ses héros sont toujours empreints
d'une certaine poésie philosophie de
voix là et on retrouve énormément sa
danse et d'yves saint laurent vous
l'avez lu et bien non pas son nom bon
vous vous laissez le une partie du
boulot veille tenait mon ce partage à
vos collaborateurs très bien donc on va
paître le dit antoine choplin quelques
jours dans la vie de thomas koussa ont
dit qu ça repousse à sa légende serait
taillé je ne peins pas concepteur ces
cours sont en tout cas qu'ils récusent à
la plaque la fosse aux ours
et ça a l'air tout à fait tout à fait
passionnant alors moi je vais vous
présenter un ouvrage de la rentrée la
qui vraiment m'a passionné là où j'ai
appris plein plein de choses
quelle histoire mondiale de la france
l'histoire mondiale de la france
éditions du seuil
est ce qu'on appelle un pavé ce sac est
dirigé par patrick boucheron s'est fait
de façon chronologique
ça commence à - 34 milles avant
jésus-christ jusqu'à de nos jours avec
plein de petits renvoie donc quand on
voit un événement on peut sauter vers un
autre événement pour se promener tout un
tout à travers ce livre est là aussi
c'est un ouvrage politique patrick
boucheron me dit au bout de trois lignes
de l'ouvragé c'est fait c'est l'histoire
de commandes la france a été façonnée au
niveau 2
enfin l'histoire de la france vis-à-vis
du monde et comment aussi la
mondialisation a pu façonner l'histoire
de la france voilà donc c'est vraiment
passionnant c'est l'anti lorànt deutsch
c'est ça hein en quelque sorte
maintenant venez donc là en même temps
c'est pas la mêlée de d2 sont bien moi
je vais j'aime beaucoup et lorànt
deutsch quand je donne aussi du regain
de ces deux régions russes histoire
c'est ça ouais c'est pas là c'est aussi
l'histoire globale de la france
alors vincent pêche vous vous êtes
maître de conférence et donc vous venez
défendre ce livre nous présenter parce
que parce que vous avez un invité je
crois que vous recevez bientôt l'auteur
oui c'est ça alors là j'en suis aussi
l'un des auteurs
quant à remixer 922 hauteur pour cent
quarante six dates au total donc voyez
que nous sommes nombreux
je ne sais pas si leur hangar et a lu le
livre en entier mais moi je ne lis pas
encore lune ont fait d'un entier
qu'est-ce que j'ai fait comme d'hab
alors moi j'ai fait la date de 177 sur
les martyrs de lyon les premiers martyrs
chrétiens d'occident en dehors de rome
il se trouve qu'ils sont en gaule à lyon
et comme disait laurent il y à des
renvois dans l'ouvragé on apprend par
exemple que à la date de 1308 il a fallu
attendre cette date pour que lyon
appartiennent au royaume de france
lyon était jusque là en terre dans pire
est donc toute cette mémoire des martyrs
de lyon le fait que l'archevêque de lyon
et primat des gaules
voilà bien être à 108 à l'égal du pape
et de l'empereur le roi de france à lyon
voilà nous nous y sommes en plein dedans
et donc ça c'est ça c'est votre
contribution non la mienne ses 177 mana
coloris orange doigt pour expliquer que
lyon appartenait au royaume de france
qu'à partir de gaz placées en 1308
habitants comme lundi 07 un ouvrage qui
interroge la continuité l'histoire de
france qui montrent que ce n'est pas si
évident que cela que l'histoire que la
france n'est pas née telle qu'elle est
aujourd'hui
dès le bien sûr et en même temps c'est
un ouvrage qui aussi laisse une grande
part aux plaisirs du récit et c'est un
ouvrage qui s'adresse à qui est-ce que
tout est ce que tout le monde peut le
lire est-ce que c'est très grand public
ou est-ce qu'il faut déjà un petit peu
de un certain bagage
c'est un ouvrage pas encore ce public
cultivé d'accord que selon les articles
la part du récit est plus ou moins
importante il y a de la réflexion l'idée
que nous avons eues en faisant cet
ouvrage c'est qu'il fallait mettre à la
portée du grand public la manière dans
l'histoire se fait dans les universités
mais pas de manière ennuyeuse est-ce
qu'on peut picorer alors on ne vise pas
de a à z c'est juste avoir une envie et
une curiosité enfin tous des gars comme
il y en avoir un grand bagage scolaire
c'est juste d'avoir envie d'apprendre
des choses sur la france et ses environs
se promènent et voilà et on passe deux
heures à avoir parcouru certaines datent
un peu en avant un pas en arrière
vraiment c et les récits voilà il ya
quand même de la place pour les récits
donc c'est vraiment très intéressant
alors comment recevez-vous l'auteur
enfin le fait pas l'auteur des coups
j'ai donc 122 hauteur mais mais le le
vieil ouvrage directeur et professeur au
collège de france alain très occupé mais
nous allons recevoir à l'université de
versailles saint quentin à guyancourt
mardi 24 janvier dans l'amphithéâtre
montesquieu jeu fans publie un peu de
publicité assez bien dans sa relation
qui sera un peu plus longue nous allons
recevoir un des quatre coordinateur qui
s'appelle yann potin qui travaille aux
archives nationales
et il se trouve que dans cette
université nous sommes deux à avoir
écrit dans cet ouvrage ma collègue
pauline le maigre
rae le maigre et spécialiste de
versailles d'accord et donc c'est cette
conférence est dans le cadre de votre
laboratoire dipak c ça voilà donc vous
rappelez nous un petit peu ce que c'est
encore une fois que deepak parce que je
suis pas sûr que tout le monde est alors
d une connaissance parfaite de
l'acronyme dynamique patrimoniale et
culturelle c'est un laboratoire
d'histoire qui valent de l'antiquité
jusqu'à la révolution mais où nous
accent sur l'histoire culturelle sur les
questions du patrimoine de la mémoire
voilà la raison de ce titre d'accord
donc on appelle un petit peu le titre du
livre histoire mondiale de la france et
publié au seuil
c'est un gros pavé on va un peu parlé
des prix parce que tout ça c'est quand
même important le prix d'un livre 29
euros bon au poids c'est pas si cher que
ça il faut non je voudrais rassurer les
lecteurs
c'est quand même c'est ce qu on y attend
voilà je pense que voilà ça paraît sa
part un très bon du moins bon et bien il
nous reste pas très faim pas tellement
pas tellement de temps
dernier livre laurent groff les furies
lauren groves j'aurai la classe voilà
ses livres préférés d'obama paraît-il en
fait ils n'ont pas préféré il a dit que
c'était le livre qu'il veut le meilleur
livre qui les lui pour 2015 voilà donc
je ne connais pas bien ce qu'il est mais
effectivement c'est un excellent
entourage ça je dois l'avouer en deux
parties alors que ce qui fait la vie
d'un couple sur 25 30 ans à peu près lui
est un fils de riche industriel floride
qui pour des raisons va être enfin pour
l'écarter en fait de mauvaises
fréquentations va être envoyé en
internat dans le nord et l on sait pas
bien d'où elle vient et en fait toute la
première partie du livre c'est lui qui
raconte son histoire son enfance son
adolescence avec des petites gens c'est
un livre à deux voies mais c'est un
livre surtout qui quand on lit cette
deuxième voie qui fait complètement
basculé le roman dire que la deuxième
voie c'est une vraie tempête c'est une
bombe dans le roman c'est presque une
surprise c'est concédés coup de théâtre
on tombe vraiment de haut et en fait non
c'est ça qui m'a plu laurent vous avez
été sensible aussi à ce coup de théâtre
vous l'avez pas lui non plus non ma joue
et ne réfère il faudrait que vous suivez
les conseils quand même de vous libre
alors et s'ils avaient tous y avait
trois lits pour notre invité parmi ces
trois là celui là lui faut lui conseille
de kent les furies nos ateliers en temps
il ya une valeur voilà pour notre invité
ben écoute et non vincent peillon vous
remercie beaucoup d'être venu le voit on
ira assister à votre conférence de plus
24 janvier voilà avec la librairie huy
ha vu est organisé conjointement sa
stéphanie merci beaucoup merci à laurent
à très bientôt très bientôt jean charte
merci pour ce succès bonne dose de
lecture et puis nous on se retrouve très
bientôt sûrement bonne journée
[Musique]